you still man the case that dogecoin is
uh i guess the second best
cryptocurrency or if you don't consider
bitcoin a cryptocurrency but instead of
crypto property i would classify it as
crypto property because the us dollar is
a currency so unless your crypto asset
is pegged algorithmically or stably to
the value the dollar is not a currency
it's a property or it's an asset
so then can you still man the case that
dogecoin is the best cryptocurrency then
because bitcoin is not even in that list
the debate is going to be whether it's
property or security and there's a
debate whether it's decentralized enough
so
let's assume it was decentralized yep
well it's it's increasing at not quite
five what five percent a year inflation
rate but it's it's not five percent
exponentially it's like a plus five
million
five percent something captain is less
i forget the exact number but it's an
inflationary property it's got a lower
inflation rate
than the u.s dollar
and it's got a much lower inflation rate
than than uh many other fiat currencies
so i think you could say that but don't
you see the power of meme the power of
ideas the power of
uh fun or whatever mechanism is used to
uh
cap captivate a community i do but laura
meme stocks it doesn't absolve you of
your ethical and securities liabilities
if you're you know if you're promoting
it so like like i i don't have a problem
with like people buying a stock
it's just uh
the way i divide the world is right
there's investment there's saving and
there's speculation and there's trading
so bitcoin
is an asset for saving if you want to
save money for 100 years you don't
really want to take on execution risk
or the like so you're just buying
something to hold forever for for you to
actually endorse something as a property
like if you said to me mike what should
i
buy for the next hundred years i say
well some amount of real estate some
amount of scarce collectibles some
amount of bitcoin right you can run your
company
right but but running your company is an
investment so the savings are properties
if you said what should i invest in i'd
say well here's a list of good companies
private companies you can start your own
company that's an investment
right
if you said what should i trade
well i'm trading as like a proprietary
thing like i'm i don't i don't have any
special
insight into that if you're a good
trader you know you are if you said to
me what should you speculate in
we talk about meme stocks
and meme coins
and and it's kind of sits up there it
sits right in the same space with what
horse should you bet on and what sports
team should you gamble on and should you
bet on black six times in a row and
double down each time
that's i mean it's fun but
at the end of the day
it's uh it's a speculation right you
can't build a civilization on
speculation on it it's not an
institutional asset and in fact
where i leave it right is bitcoin is
clearly digital progress which makes it
an institutional grade investable asset
for a public company a public figure a
public investor or anybody that's risk
adverse
i think that uh the other the top 100
other cryptos are like venture capital
investments and if you're a vc and if
you're a qualified technical investor
and you have a pool of capital and you
can take that kind of risk
then you can parse through that and form
opinions it's just
orders of magnitude more risky because
of competition because of ambition and
because of regulation
and if you take the meme coins it's like
you know when some rapper comes out with
a meme coin it's like
maybe it'll peak when i hear about it
right it's like
i mean ship was created as the coin such
that it had so many zeros after the
decimal point that when you looked at it
on the exchanges it always showed zero
zero zero zero
and it wasn't until like six months
after it got popular that they started
expanding the display so you could see
whether the price had changed
you